[Music]
hey good evening everybody and welcome
to Tucker tonight i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm gonna be filling in for Tucker for
the entire hour
apparently the dubious use of emails can
run in families it turns out embattled
Hillary Clinton aide uma Abidine might
have been the chief of staff had she won
is not the only one in her family linked
to an email controversy that news is the
State Department releases more of Houmas
own emails from her time and the Clinton
State Department remember the emails
were found on our ex-husbands
laptop Fox News chief national
correspondent and Henry is here with
some all new email developments hey Edie
Bryan great to see you home Avenue and
probably just wants this year to be over
it began with the reality setting in
that her patron Hillary Clinton was not
going to be President Donald Trump was
being inaugurated dear ended with more
family drama in November her estranged
husband Anthony Weiner began serving a
21 month sentence following his
conviction of sexting with an underage
girl today the State Department a new
batch of emails as you noted from
weiners laptop remember the existence of
those emails led then FBI director James
Comey to reopen the Clinton's server
probe near the end of the 2016 election
then call me and the FBI basically
cleared everyone and they claimed to the
public at the time most of these emails
on the laptop were duplicates and not
really a big deal well breaking tonight
we're learning there were several emails
on the Weiner laptop that he shared with
Aberdeen that had classified information
at least one of those documents sent
from the laptop to Clinton while she was
Secretary of State in 2012 and it had
the label quote-unquote classified also
breaking this week as you noted a first
cousin of Aberdeen was convicted Tuesday
in a fraud case involving wait for it
fake emails 44 year old Omar Amana faces
more than a decade in prison after a
jury in New York found he he and
associate were guilty of cooking the
books and defrauding shareholders at the
tech company KITT Digital Hama Nets
brother also arrested in the United Arab
Emirates according to the New York Post
a judge in the case revoked Alma Knotts
bail after he was deemed a flight risk
the father of six tried to fool the jury
by introducing yes fake emails into the
record trying to pass it off as evidence
that would vindicate him during the 2016
campaign
the New York Post also reported
Aventine spent more than a decade
editing a radical muslim muslim
publication that opposed women's rights
and blamed the u.s. for the 9/11 terror
attacks a far cry from the way clinton
and associates like Aventine presented
themselves in that losing campaign but
again this is a year that she clearly
wants over bryan right and think of what
could have been in her mind she might
have been chief of staff when those
powerful women in the entire country
hence the entire world instead we're
still wondering about her lapse of
judgment bringing back those emails to
her house four of which at least were
classified to Anthony Weiner who clearly
has some trust issues right yeah I mean
look he was no longer in Congress when
he had access to some of this
information clearly didn't have a
security clearance and this is gonna
raise questions about why Hillary
Clinton was let off the hook but again
it's also gonna raise questions about
why James Comey decided to insert
himself late in the election season and
suggest that Hillary Clinton still had
an email problem in October on the eve
of the election and then a few days
later said well now never mind she's
been vindicated the emails are not a
problem we're looking at them tonight
Brian and as you say several of them had
classified information so it's gonna
raise a lot of questions
Ede great job as usual it's a great new
year see you soon the new year